dans new york la ville la plus
cosmopolite au monde certains ressentent
un malaise les étudiants originaires du
monde arabe et musulman doivent
affronter les regards d'une société
profondément traumatisée aujourd'hui il
leur est plus difficile d'obtenir des
visas pour venir étudier reportage de
jean marc pitte et christian de carnet
au coeur de manhattan
tout autour de washington square et
noailles ou new york university la plus
grande facture et d'amérique
parmi les cinquante mille étudiants qui
la fréquentent une forte proportion
d'étrangers et notamment des jeunes
issus de pays arabes ou musulmans pour
eux depuis le 11 septembre 2001 la vie
est devenue difficile
juste après les importants alors gelé
sur le quai du métro un des agresseurs
lui ont placé un couteau sous la gorge
en expliquant qu'il voulait tuer des
arabes et des musulmans
nombre d'entre nous ont du mal à trouver
du travail je devais passer un entretien
dans une entreprise vous avez envoyé mon
cv
j'ai appelé un responsable qui m'a
demandé d'où j'étais je lui ai dit que
j'étais né en arabie saoudite
il m'a demandé si j'étais musulman j'ai
répondu oui et il a raccroché
la pression vient également du
gouvernement américain
il oblige les universités à transmettre
au département d'état des informations
très précises sur l'assiduité des
étudiants étrangers
si elle est jugée insuffisante ils
peuvent être expulsés
c'est un contrôle qui n'existaient
jamais avant c'est très difficile à
justifier
je crois que maintenant c'est très
difficile d'avoir un visa pour venir ici
et je crois que même je sais que
l'université ici de lanouaille ou trouve
pas mal de difficultés pour obtenir des
visas pour les étudiants de de tout le
monde en fait tous les étrangers mais
pas en particulier tout ce qui est arabe
et musulman bassem et faycelles le
reconnaissent la ville de new york reste
malgré ce qu'elle a vécu plus
accueillante pour les étrangers que
n'importe quel endroit des états unis
mais ces deux étudiants de troisième
cycle ont aussi la sensation d'être en
permanence suspecté d'être de potentiels
terroristes
voilà le profil des étudiants arabes aux
états unis déjà ça c'est le profil du
terrorisme aujourd'hui
et bien sûr qu'on en août s avant
peut-être qu'ils ne regardaient qui me
travers mais maintenant ils n'ont pas
honte ils le font ouvertement
directement et ils ont le droit de le
faire mais bassem et faycelles ont fait
leur choix ils préfèrent enduré ces
conditions désormais plus difficile et
finir leurs études aux états unis